une convention de partenariat
contractuelle c'est la conseillère
exécutive en charge de la santé des
solidarités Audrey talibardol qui a
soumis ce matin au conseiller
territoriaux l'un des dispositifs pour
accompagner ceux qui sont à l'étranger
ou dans l'Hexagone et qui veulent
revenir travailler en Martinique il
s'agit d'une convention qui sera signée
avec la société hosanna mais plus
précisément avec son actionnaire
majoritaire Action Logement cette
convention privée de mettre la
disposition de ce qui reviennent au pays
50 logements gratuits le temps pour ses
futurs locataires de se trouver un
appartement
nous aurons quand même un comité qui va
regrouper les partenaires pour pouvoir
déterminer les différentes attributions
pour les personnes ce sera une période
de trois mois puisque bien sûr il faut
que ça soit mis à disposition de
l'ensemble des arrivants donc cette
commission
déterminera les critères et bien sûr la
mise à disposition pendant trois mois de
manière à les accompagner dans la
nouvelle recherche de logement de leur
installation c'est 50 logements meublés
seront disponibles pour les étudiants
mais aussi pour des actifs qui
souhaitent revenir au pays ils seront
attribués sur dossier par une commission
dont les membres seront de la CTM et
bien sûr d'Action Logement l'attribution
de ces appartements fait partie d'un
dispositif déjà voté en février dernier
la maison du retour
nous allons dans un premier temps faire
une gestion prévisionnelle des effectifs
des emplois et des compétences parce que
ça nous permettra d'avoir un état des
lieux des besoins sur notre territoire
en termes d'emploi bien entendu
accompagné aussi cette démarche et
accompagner les familles qui viendront
s'installer vous avez suffisamment
entendu parler de l'aide à la prime de
natalité mais pas que puisque nous
allons aussi financer l'ensemble des
manuels scolaires dans les
établissements de Martinique et enfin
d'autres mesures environ le jour comme
par exemple la création d'une bourse
très spéciale pour les étudiants en
médecine mais attention il ne
l'apercevront qu'à condition qu'il
s'engage à revenir exercer en Martinique